[Music]
these days the news is full of heavy
information so we thought we'd take a
break from that and share a bunch of
light fun facts in a segment called did
you know
tarik and i will go back and forth
saying fun little facts that we think
you might not know you ready tarek yep
yay okay i'll go first
did you know that dolphins sleep with
one eye open it's a way to avoid being
eaten by their predators
that explains the old saying you can't
sneak up on a dolphin it sure does
did you know that someone buys a jar
nutella every 2.5 seconds i believe it
nutella is delicious
hey tarik yeah did you know that after
the civil war three amendments were
passed by congress the 13th amendment
which abolished slavery the 14th
amendment which gave african americans
equal protection under the law and the
15th amendment which prohibited
disenfranchising voters on account of
race color or previous condition of
servitude but the 15th amendment didn't
provide automatic voting rights for
african americans and congress didn't
really enforce it anyway and tennessee
didn't even ratify that amendment until
1997.
did you know that
no
no uh i i didn't
did you know the inventor of the
pringles can is buried in one
i guess once you pop you can't stop
yeah did you know that by 1870 28 states
had adopted laws prohibiting convicted
felons from voting a move designed
specifically to disenfranchise black
voters and that southern states adopted
jim crow laws that charge poll taxes
which discouraged black people who could
not afford them from voting
um
did you know uh that a dentist invented
cotton candy
i did not know that
that's like a doctor inventing cirrus
yeah
did you know that poll taxes continued
into the 20th century and that literacy
tests were also implemented that
discriminated against african americans
who were descendants of the slaves who
were not allowed to read or write due to
anti-literacy laws but white men who
could not pass the literacy test were
able to vote due to the grandfather
clause allowing them to vote if their
grandfathers voted by 1897 did you know
did you know did you know that
no
these are supposed to be fun facts right
yeah
because
because it seems like mine are fun
but yours is starting to be a little
more centered around one serious fact
really i hadn't noticed that how about
this
did you know that otter sleep holding
hands
i didn't
that is a fun fact what's not fun though
is that the 19th amendment which gave
women the right to vote did not
guarantee black women the right to vote
that is not fun
but it is a fact
okay i felt like this was gonna be like
a fun light-hearted segment turk as
black people living in america we don't
have the luxury of being lighthearted
now that's a fact
[Laughter]
spin did you know
[Music]
you